من الاردن سالنا الناس ما هو اكثر ما يضيع
وقتك عليه
[موسيقى]
يعني قراءه الكتب هو القصص
يعني على الانستغرام سناب شات والفيسبوك
[موسيقى]
والايام العاديه يعني هيك الواحد بجد وقته
يعني قصدي اغراض بيته اييي تابع امور
اولاده
والمساء والله يعني بصراحه يعني بنروح عند
اصحابنا بنلعب شده غالبين ومغلوفين انت
اكثر شيء بضيع وقت او باخد وقتي هو الشغل
للمدرسه هاي الشغله الاولى والشغله
الثانيه التلفون يعني تلفون صراحه حتى هو
اكثر من انه بقي شاب مجتمع كله يعني حتى
مع الاطفال اذا بتلاحظين يعني هسه اي ام
بدها تخلص من ابنها مباشره
على التعلق بالتليفون هذا مصيبه بصراحه
على شغلتين اللي هي الاولى يعني على التيك
توك والشغل الثاني على بي ان سبورت قنوات
الرياضيه في كاس العالم بالوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]